it's time for an important Hannity watch
tonight on the radical socialist
Democrats that want to be the next
president of the United States of
America so last night
fake News CNN dedicated a whopping seven
long miserable hours to one topic
climate change now it was essentially a
marathon infomercial for the DNC all
things Democrat and by the way for the
record the ratings frankly sucked
marginally better from there usually
disastrous numbers but a flop a failure
by any TV objector objective measure
let's put it this way thanks to you and
we mean this with all our hearts and
souls thank you for giving us this this
TV set every night joining us every
night we had well over two million
viewers more than their unusually
marginally higher number we do thank you
for your support you make this show
possible we never forget that but over
the fake news over there at CNN hour
after hour the network provided ten
Democratic presidential candidates a
platform to share their radical and I
mean radical plans for saving mother
earth from its imminent destruction it
was all one big lie one excuse for
Democrats and of course the media mob
that supports them to push their radical
extreme socialist agenda and trash
American capitalism which created the
greatest wealth in the history of
mankind don't be fooled last night was
not about clean air water it was all
about government complete total control
over our lives your lives the candidates
on fake news CNN they made it perfectly
clear they want to control what you eat
maybe invest in cows if they ever get
elected how you commute to work what
kind of job you have what kind of car
you drive how much energy you consume
and even what kind of and I happen to
love plastic straws myself I will arm
her and whether or not you're allowed
plastic straws even worse one candidate
get this proposing using abortion as a
as a control of population in poor
countries is pretty twisted ugly sick
and and frankly repulsive
and of course every Democrat heaping
praise on the green New Deal which
abolishes our free market system in
exchange for false assurances to
alleviate all of your worries in life
just think keep your doctor keep your
plan and save money didn't happen just
think Solyndra a waste of money
you get free higher education you get
free health care free vacation free
green housing free healthy food
universal basic income you lose your
right to private insurance but who cares
right
also it calls for no more cows no more
air travel no more nuclear energy
no more combustion engine no more coal
no more oil and gas the lifeblood of
every economy especially ours and the
one thing that will raise the standard
of living of every single American if
only we would use our resources share it
with the American people we'll be rich
again this plan would also send us into
a great depression probably within hours
of its implementation and gut our
inalienable rights well in just a moment
we're going to show you all the dumb and
in some cases scary and chilling and
frightening proposals from last night's
town hall but first we bring in some
important context to the left non-stop
the sky is falling rhetoric surrounding
last night's seven long pathetic hours
on climate change it is now time for a
Hannity history lesson on the horribly
wrong predictions flawed science
politically motivated outrage about the
future of this wonderful planet you know
remember God told job he set the
foundations for the earth the majesty of
God's creation we can't even begin to
fathom now when we think about it can we
universes within universes within
universes but we should start in the
1970s we had Liberal Democrat socialist
then a few decades ago along with some
prominent liberal scientists so-called
scholars they were sounding a desperate
alarm about the coming ice age and
global cooling one prominent ecologist
stated quote if the present trends
continue the world will be about four
degrees colder for the global mean
temperature nineteen
but 11 degrees colder in the year 2000
this is about twice what it would take
to put us into that Ice Age and Harvard
biologist George Wald claimed quote
civilization will end within fifteen or
thirty years unless immediate action is
taken against the problems facing
mankind and of course the media mob
echoing the scientific community's panic
1974 take a look
Time magazine wondering if another ice
age is on the way 1975 Newsweek
dedicating a massive report to the quote
cooling world of course there was no ice
age in the 90s civilization did not end
in fact these exact opposite happened
worldwide population boomed life
expectancy increased the standard of
living around the globe especially here
improved dramatically that didn't stop
the scientific community or so-called
scientific community just like the
so-called media and Democrats from
making wild end-of-days predictions one
after another the AP 1989 reporting
quote a senior UN environmental official
says entire nations could be wiped off
the face of the earth by the rising sea
levels or would now want a global
warming well oh we left the Ice Age if
the global warming trend is not reversed
by the year 2000 in 2006 remember Al
Gore lunatic that he is warning less
drastic measures to reduce greenhouse
gases are taken within the next 10 years
the world will reach a point of no
return
well wait past the 10 year mark for
decades we saw one false tire warning
after another over and over and over
again here's just a small example I wish
I had time I could run the whole hour of
this take a look the planet has a fever
if your baby has a fever you go to the
doctor but this is what would happen to
Manhattan
[Music]
they can measure this precisely just as
the scientists could predict precisely
how much water would breach the levees
in New Orleans the area where the World
Trade Center Memorial is to be located
would be underwater ice caps could melt
raising the level of the Seas possible
probable we really don't know but if it
happens it means goodbye Miami
goodbye Corpus Christi goodbye
sacramentum goodbye Boston one scientist
put the urgency of the greenhouse
potential in biblical terms citing the
warning given to Noah in the Old
Testament Noah knew trouble was coming
he said and he prepared for it ah the
medium mob back then now you saw some
footage from Al Gore's An Inconvenient
Truth 2007 it was actually a British
judge ruling that the film was not
suitable for kids in classrooms because
of all of its false claims now one such
claim involves polar bears
Al Gore implied that the animals were a
doomed species well today polar bears
have seen an explosion in population and
recently the left has blamed all extreme
weather now okay there's no more cooling
of the earth there's no Ice Age we're
not going to burn up so we'll just say
climate change and won't that be if it
gets hot or cold we can say it's climate
change and we're responsible they claim
the weather has become worse it's
killing Americans and increasing numbers
that too is a lie take a look at your
screen 2018 fewer Americans killed by
floods lightning tornadoes hurricanes
and heat than the 30-year national
average now don't get me wrong I believe
we should be good stewards of God's
gifts clean air water are important but
we're not dealing with the apocalyptic
it scenario they keep laying out and on
fake news CNN last night
none of these facts seem to matter well
Blitzer he went full on Alexandria
Acacio Cortes on us and even blamed
hurricane Dorian which is hitting during
hurricane season in a hurricane prone
area of the world on climate change take
a look we have 11 years to avoid the
catastrophic consequences of
this crisis food shortages rising
sea-levels more extreme weather events
like hurricane durian that's turning
toward the Carolinas right now well
stick to the conspiracy theories what
you're used to that claim pretty stupid
but it only got worse from there now
naturally you have sleepy creepy crazy
well Joe 303 300 by Dhin whose eye is
filled with blood kind of rambling
incoherently last night but even worse
multiple candidates on that stage are
comparing the struggles against
so-called climate change to America's
fight against Nazi Germany in World War
two Nazism fascism Tojo's Japan really
mayor Pete one of the reasons I love the
framing of the green New Deal
is it uses some of the language that we
might associate with the way that we met
the response of Nazi Germany in World
War two just like the greatest
generation 1 World War 2 and just like
the civil rights movement I just waved
under our channel because this is the
hardest thing we will have done
certainly in my lifetime as a country
this is on par with winning World War
two perhaps even more challenging than
that what do you try governings South
Bend Indiana first because you're not
doing a great job there well more
challenging than winning World War two
my father for years in the Pacific
millions of people died in World War two
there's mayor Pete and the others do
they want to tell the greatest
generation that driving a Prius is
tougher than storming the beaches of
Normandy does he need to relearn the
horrors of the Holocaust just like the
squad members that regularly compare
well a lot of things to Nazi
concentration camps this climate change
hysteria is frankly pretty insulting and
so are the Democrats radical plans to
battle this fake crisis they want a ban
regulate pretty much everything you can
think of and we've got the tape to prove
it take a look let's talk about offshore
drilling foil would you ban it yes
absolutely did you ban offshore drilling
absolutely yes I will ban offshore
drilling so would you be on offshore
drilling yes there's no question I'm in
favor of banning fracking lobby thinking
the drawers are a big thing right now
yeah do you ban plastic straws I think
we should we are saying that we're going
to end factory farming because that is
not only that is a danger to the
environment and to climate change coal
burning plants no one's going to build
another coal burning we've got to shut
the ones down we have but no one is
going to build a new one we have to take
the cake combustion engine vehicles off
the road as rapidly as we can
oh excuse me we can rightly mock the
proposed bans on my favorite plastic
straw and burgers put the calls to
eliminate oil and gas production okay
that would be a death blow to our
economy plus it would be a massive gift
the Vladimir Putin you know the hostile
actor who runs the hostile regime in
Russia you know the same Russia that
Hillary Clinton got her lying dossier
from to try and rig the election well
his hostile regime depends on one thing
oil and gas you want to bring Putin to
his knees I'll produce them and get it
to our allies a decrease in American oil
production that would mean Russia would
dominate the market that would
strengthen Putin's authoritarian grip in
Europe that what the Democrats want and
by the way in case you're wondering the
price tag of the Democrats climate
change proposal well that's totally
insane to look at these numbers we're
gonna have to spend a lot of federal
money in order to deal with the crisis
two hundred and fifty billion dollars
immediately your climate change plan
talks about spending 1.7 trillion two
trillion dollar plan I've got a one
trillion dollar plan a two trillion to
three trillion dollar range senator
Booker you've recently unveiled a three
trillion dollar plan to tackle climate
change five trillion dollars five
trillion dollar plan 16 trillion dollar
plan whoa
for context understand the entire
federal budgets around four trillion
dollars a year look at your screen each
and every candidate they want to add
trillions of dollars in spending 16
trillion Bernie
that means trillions of dollars of new
tax
is an economy that you're destroying and
most of the candidates they support a
variety of other new taxes income taxes
sales taxes carbon taxes wealth taxes
well that would dramatically increase by
the way the carbon attacked the cost of
energy for every American
but just remember corporations don't pay
taxes they pass the cost on to you
that carbon tax that wouldn't even be
enough for Bernie's plan and 16 trillion
dollars trillion with a T in news
spending just on climate programs and
Bernie Sanders also seems to echo the
sick the twisted the vile philosophy a
Planned Parenthood founder Margaret
Sanger with his sick ugly repulsive
support for worldwide abortions to
control populations in poor countries is
this the new democratic party take a
look educating everyone on the need to
curb population growth seems a
reasonable campaign to enact would you
be courageous enough to discuss this
issue and make it a key feature of a
plan to address climate catastrophe well
multi dancers yes and the answer has
everything to do with the fact that
women in the United States of America by
the way have a right to control their
own bodies especially in poor countries
around the world where women do not
necessarily want to have large numbers
of babies and where they can have the
opportunity through birth control to
control the number of kids they have
something I very very strongly support
it's not the new democratic parties that
summed up pretty much sum up the night
over their fake do see you then I think
so
Democrats climate change it is only a
political tool even the chief of staff
of Acacio Cortez recognized and stated
publicly designed to trick you to give
up your liberty and your freedom and a
lot of your tax money so Democrats can
enact their vision of a socialist utopia
and so people leave New York New Jersey
Illinois in California they'll be
leaving America if this is ever
implemented god forbid now 2020 this
election is the biggest choice election
of our lifetimes this is about living
free or America as we know it dies and
the future of our country the free world
is at stake
before we get to our guests let me
address one glaring example of fake news
media pious almost well pretty much
every newsroom in America screwed this
up and lied to you by accusing the
president of lying now the President
issued this tweet oh look at that that's
from I think August 29th and 30th
proving the president what he said about
the earlier models about Hurricane
Dorian that it might hit Alabama is true
but if you watch the media mob you would
think the president was lying as they
always do just another absurd example of
Trump derangement syndrome take a look
the White House is falsifying weather
reports so that it doesn't have to admit
the president who spent the weekend
golfing was not up to date on the storms
forecast Donald Trump is not the
sharpest sharpie
this really fits a pattern of the
president putting out misleading
information the initial reaction is to
laugh out loud
it's laugh out loud funny it's so absurd
but the other aspect of it borders on
being truly dangerous the Democrats keep
looking for an impeachment inquiry to go
this is actually against the law and
this might actually be crumbs for them
to say wait a second you know well it's
right there a lot of psychotic jackasses
and the media mob I'm sure will get
their apology that'll be forthcoming
which had time to name every name